ما اقسى ان تفقد امام ناظريك من كنت تحلم
لهم وبهم اكثر من 25 الف مهاجر غير نظامي
وارتهم ووارد احلامهم مياه البحر الابيض
المتوسط غرقا او فردا منذ عام 2014 وفق
تقارير دوليه هذه الايام نعيش اجواء ماساه
غرق وفقد مئات المهاجرين غير النظاميين من
بينهم سوريون
ومصريون
وباكستانيون وبالت السواحل اليونانيه وفي
فبراير الماضي لقي قرابه 100 مهاجر غير
نظامي مصرعهم من بينهم عشرات الاطفال
قباله ساحل في جنوب ايطاليا جراء تحطم
قاربهم لنشاهد القصه اولا بدات الشعله
الاولى للحراقه في المغرب العربي عام 95
كنتيجه لتضييق بعض الدول الاوروبيه القيود
على المهاجرين وعرفوا تاريخيا بالحراقه
لانهم كانوا يحرقون وثائقهم عند الوصول
الى اوروبا ثم امتدت هذه الظاهره في
السنوات الاخيره الى دول الشرق الاوسط عام
2022 بالتحديد هو عام صارخ جدا بارقامه
اولا زياده عدد الاشخاص يلي اخذوا البحر
بنسبه 3 اضعاف عن العام اللي سبقه يعني عن
عام 2021
ثانيا اشدنا بتزايد ركاب يلي هن ركاب
لبنانيين من جنس اللبنانيه يلي صاروا عم
ياخدوا البحر بشكل اكثر
وثلاثه وهذا امر محزن جدا شدنا على خسائر
كثير كبيره بالارواح هناك ما لا يقول عن
185 شخص فقدوا حياتهم او ما زالوا مفقودين
بالبحر
في ايام كتير
انا ومرتي
ومحمد وجاد وين ما بكون هم معي وين ما
بتطلع عن القدامي نحن طالعين بالبحر
دولتنا قتلتنا بقلب البحر رجعت انا
والشبان والبنتين
الامل الوحيد هو هذا البحر ونطلع من
هالبلد
نسب المهاجرين عام 2022 بين السوريين
ولبنانيين وفلسطينيين ليتصدر السوريون
النسبه الاعلى من المهاجرين انا بالنسبه
الي فقدت قدمت للامن العام ورفضوا الاقامه
واعطوني سفر يعتبر انا هلا غير قانوني ما
عندي حل لالي قادر ارجع على بلدي وللي
قادر ابقى هون فما عندي خيار تاني
اول شيء انا دفعت النص وبس لاوصل بعد فتره
ندفع النص الثاني
[موسيقى]
اما روايه الجيش اللبناني فترجع سبب الغرق
الى اصطدام قارب المهاجرين بمركب الجيش
وليس العكس ضلينا شي ساعه ونص احنا بالمي
بالبرد هو ما عاد عرفت شيء عن اولادي اجمل
ولا برات اللانش ولا هي الدوله اخذتهم
اكثر من 80 شخصا 30 منهم ما زالوا في عداد
المفقودين بينما تم انتشال سبع جثث فقط
وانقاذوا 45 للاسف حتى اليوم ما في اهتمام
جدي من القضاء بهذه القضيه حيصيرنا سنه
تقريبا وما زاد الملف بين مديريه
المخابرات بين النيابه العامه العسكريه
الاجهزه القضائيه اللبنانيه والقوى
العسكريه والامنيه معنيه
بوضع اليد بشكل كامل على التحقيقات
الجاريه وبالتالي التوقيف المتورطين بهذه
المنظمه بالاضافه لعملياتنا اليوميه
المهمه من اوفياء بتتشدد اعمالنا اول شيء
الدوريات على الشواطئ البحري لاسيما منطقه
الشمال بتتكثف عمليات الاستقصاءات
والاستعلام وجمع المعلومات وتبادل
المعلومات بيننا وبين الاجهزه الامنيه
تحول الحلم
الاومينا المهاجرين الناجين ولعائلاتهم
بعد فقدان ابنائهم واقاربهم
انا بقول لهم اولادي بقلب البحر انا بروح
لعندهم في احتمال اني افقد حياتي وحياته
بهاي وفي احتمال كمان اللي على اذا وصلت
لهونيك يقدروا يعيشوا اولاده اللي بموت
بموت مره واحده
هلا كل يوم
من شان يقدروا يجوا من الحدود اللبنانيه
السوريه
شخص من كل اسبوع من معبر واحد بيكلفني شخص
من سوريا على لبنان 100 دولار هؤلاء كذلك
موجودين في الدول الاوروبيه وبامكاننا
مساءلتهم كذلك واريد ان اؤكد نعم هذه
مسؤوليه المهربين لكن رجاء فلتاخذ بنظر
الاعتبار بان الدول الاوروبيه لديها
مسؤوليه كبيره في هذا الاطار ما يقومون به
فيما يخص الدفع بعيدا بالمهاجرين الدفع
بعيدا ممن يسعون للحصول على اللجوء
السياسي لو عادت الذاكره الان قليلا الى
الوراء هل كنت
لتختار نفس الطريق
انه انا ومرتي الله يرحمهم انه نطلع على
بلد يكون تعاملنا بانسانيه ونعيش عيشه
كريمه قام راحوا عند ربهم سبحان الله
هذا رجع فين الزمن اكيد لا ابدا